i think what has to happen is all of our
elected representatives
have to hear more from a broad cross
section of liberals libertarians
conservatives
people who just want to say this is too
much big government we want our
government i'm nick gillespie with
reason tv and today we're talking with
susan herman who's the president of the
aclu but also the author of taking
liberties the war on terror and the
erosion of american democracy susan
thanks for talking to us
thank you nick thanks for having me
we've discussed that i can't pronounce
most names that are going to come up in
this conversation already but
it's not covered in your book but it is
very much in the news the
killing of the american citizen anwar
al-awlak
okay of the u.s on direct orders from
the president the aclu had
filed a lawsuit on behalf of al-awaki's
father last year in july what was your
lawsuit
and how does it play into what happened
well our chief concern about this case
was the process that we don't know what
the criteria are that the president
has been using and what the limits are
on and this is he has
a kill list right or i mean this is
because any information has officially
been given to the public right
but to me if the constitution means
anything it has to mean that the
president can't just
designate an american citizen to be an
enemy and then kill them
and this wasn't even in the theater of
war your theater or formal war so the
theory is if you can kill somebody
an american citizen in yemen or pakistan
why not barcelona and why not washington
dc he hasn't
refuted any of this but he's also not
confirmed it officially but how
unprecedented is it for an american
citizen to order the assassination
of another american citizen a lot of
that goes you know behind the curtain
yeah
i think you know there are not a lot of
form certainly there's no permission to
do
such a thing and i think what this gets
to is it's one of the derivations of the
concept that we're at war
and that this is an untraditional war
and therefore the president has
untraditional powers
let's talk about that because uh george
bush talked about the war on terror the
war on terrorism
are we at war and if so does that
justify
kind of wiping away a bunch of liberty i
was a philosophy major in college and
i've often learned that if you're having
a discussion it's good to define your
terms
and to me the very definition of war
includes an element of politics
that there's a somebody on the other
side you can negotiate with
that everyone understands what the rules
are the people who are uniforms that
there's a confined theater or war
and that the work can end it can have a
treaty and a termination date
and you know when does the war on terror
end and you know who who surrenders who
writes the peace treaty
so to me we're not at war not
technically certainly
not all the consequences of being at war
would follow in the case of al qaeda in
the case of uh
terrorists who have who have committed
crimes on american soil it's obviously
not a traditional
power state power that you can declare
war on
um is how do how should we go after
terrorists then we're not saying iran
is responsible or even a iraq i mean we
invaded them for other reasons and we'll
leave that out of this discussion but
how do you go after a group like al
qaeda well i think what you just said
nick was they've committed crimes on
american soil
and i think that the criminal justice
system has been really quite effective
in prosecuting well talk about that
because this is uh people who push back
and say oh you know what if we have
military tribunals that'll
that'll help whereas in fact most of the
successful prosecutions of
conspirators and actors have actually
come through the
regular court that's right we've had
convictions of terrorists here for
terrorist plots in the regular
civilian courts so far the tribunals
have not really come up with anything
partially because
we're having a lot of disagreements
about what the appropriate procedures
should be
and whether it's fair to just come up
with procedures to try to get more
convictions
from an aclu perspective or from your
perspective
was the killing of osama bin laden
justified
he's not an american citizen let me
actually step back a minute on your
question about what's justified here
as in response to terrorism there was a
really interesting report by the
international commission of jurists
which sent an eminent
jurist panel of all sorts of people
around the world for three years
interviewing all sorts of countries that
had had challenges from terrorism
and after talking to them about how they
had changed their laws in response to
the challenge of
terrorism and how that had worked out
their primary conclusion was that the
countries that had done best
were the countries that didn't change
all their principles and all their laws
to you know rise to the occasion but
those that just shored up
when you say you did best that they
actually secured the most prosecutions
or convictions
they also you know countries were sorry
when they had sort of thrown away their
principles
and you know this ireland and argentina
and israel and all sorts of countries
so you know i think there's no reason to
be selling our principles and you're
just throwing them away
and this is fully a bipartisan kind of
cashing out of constitutional protection
because really the clinton
administration under janet reno was
pushing for much of this
already then the bush administration
created it and then
the obama administration i mean obama uh
was
uh lauded really during the campaign as
he said that he would not be acting with
the same kind of churlishness towards
constitutional precedent that bush did
but that really hasn't played out has it
he's been different in some respects and
he certainly has different uh policies
on
interrogation techniques but as to the
things i write about in my book domestic
surveillance and the things that affect
ordinary americans
his policies really have not been any
different he wants all the same dragnets
that president bush wanted starting in
the fall of 2001.
well we just celebrated the 10th
birthday of the patriot act
which opened up a wide variety of new
surveillance opportunities for the
government
talk a little bit about that how is the
patriot act continuing to be a threat to
american civil liberties
hardly anything has been changed since
the fall of 2001 there have been minor
adjustments here or there but most of it
is still exactly in place
and i'll give you one example one of the
powers that was enhanced by the patriot
act that some people have heard of by
now
are the national security letters where
the fbi can demand certain kinds of
information from telecommunications
providers
financial institutions with no court
order at all the fbi or somebody in the
federal government says hey i
this is a an investigation about
terrorism or national security concerns
i write a letter you have to give me you
must give me the information and you're
never allowed to tell anyone i asked
and you mentioned financial and
financial institutions how broadly is
that
it's an extremely broad definition
financial institution includes not only
banks it includes
car rental companies jewelers you know
casinos all sorts of places
so the fbi serves the national security
letter and for a long time i tell in my
book the stories of the librarians and
the internet service providers six
people who decided to challenge this
but what we discovered partially because
of their challenge
eventually we got some numbers and it
was in 2007 that the congress first
commissioned a report from the inspector
general about how this power was being
used
so let me tell you the period studied in
that report was 2003 to 2006.
in those years 194 000 plus
national security letters requests were
served almost 200 000
the number of terrorism convictions in
which there was evidence obtained in
that way
one what happens to that information
that is uh
compiled do we know evidently it sits in
government data banks forever yeah i
just read the figure something like 34
000 people have
access to all this information and the
government just collects
and let me tell you one more thing about
the national security letters because
the whole idea under the patriot act was
make it easier for the executive branch
to gather information they shouldn't
have to bother with courts they
shouldn't have to bother with
congressional
oversight give them the dragnet and just
trust them to use it wisely
so when the inspector general did a
study of how the
fbi was doing at policing itself it
discovered that you know the fbi had
created regulations for doing this and
then had violated its own regulations
two to three thousand times
two to three thousand times is there uh
in the wake of that report
uh and whatnot what are what are the
oversight either the congressional
or judicial oversights that have gone
into place well mostly the fbi tells us
it's doing better there's still not a
tremendous amount of oversight
we've just had the most recent renewal
of one of the controversial patriot act
provisions was
just this may may 2011 and at the
hearings on that renewal two senators
who were on the senate intelligence
committee
senators wyden and udall said that the
obama administration has adopted
what they call a twisted interpretation
of one of the patriot act powers
which they said would anger the american
people if we found out
so senator feinstein said oh yes she'd
hold hearings haven't been any hearings
one of the constant rejoinders to this
type of
conversation is to say look you know
first off you know terrorism is really
important it's an existential threat to
america whether or not that's the case
but only the guilty of something to hide
why should we worry about the government
collecting vast reams of data on people
that we're not we don't even know who
the people are or why it's being uh
okay i think two reasons first of all
the idea that collecting vast dreams of
data is going to somehow keep us safe
there's a step between the collecting
and the safe
and that's that you somehow have the
algorithms to figure out you know
patterns of terrorism a lot of the
scientists this is something i became
very skeptical of in writing the book
a lot of scientists say we're just not
there it's true that google and amazon
can figure out whether you're likely to
buy this book or what to sell you
but there aren't the kinds of patterns
of terrorism second reason why i think
we should be concerned is that with
hundreds of thousands of requests
that's not just information about guilty
people and once the government has all
that information about people
knowledge is power the framers wrote the
fourth amendment into the constitution
because they were concerned that if you
give the government too much discretion
to do searches and seizures and find out
everything everyone's doing
it gives them the power to do arbitrary
or discriminatory enforcement
give us one quick example there's at
least one documented instance in
washington state of an fbi agent asking
a librarian who checked out a particular
biography of osama bin laden
and targeting that there have been many
different people
why would anybody accept a terrorist
want to know anything about osama bin
laden
why would anybody because we're all
thinking people and we want to
understand the world
and it seems to me that one of the
problems with this whole
big brother-like regimen where the
government knows everything that we're
doing
and we conversely don't know much about
what the government is doing
is that it really creates a chilling
effect that once you know that yes
your librarian might have to tell the
government if you're checking out that
biography
and that somebody might ask that
question well why are you interested if
you're not a terrorist
you're going to become reluctant to
check out the biography i tell the story
of a graduate student at the university
of idaho
who was prosecuted for providing
material support to terrorists
because he posted links on a website
some of the links were to what jihadists
said in explaining themselves did he
support terrorism no he didn't
he was trying to promote a general
conversation now of course we should
understand
why how jihadists explain themselves
let's uh talk a little bit about another
specific case that you mentioned uh you
use a pseudonym for a woman named roya
romani who was
she now she's an iranian or she was
jailed and tortured in iran
for supporting a pro-democracy group she
gets political asylum and comes to the
united states and then what happens
and then she's arrested by the fbi and
she is prosecuted for providing material
support
to the same pro-democracy group and this
group was
labeled a terrorist group under bill
clinton
the politics behind this apparently were
that the iranian government
insisted that as for it to have any
possibility of talk or rapprochement
we had to declare their political enemy
to be terrorists
there are other countries have looked at
this and said wait a minute this isn't a
terrorist group it's a pro-democracy
group
royal romani when she was prosecuted for
this offense of supporting this this
group
wanted to tell the jury that this is not
a terrorist group that it's a
pro-democracy group
and the court's ruled that she's not
allowed to because what the government
says is final
wow and that to me is a real problem
where is she now
she's appealing her she pleaded guilty
finally they wouldn't let her raise any
defenses didn't matter that she wasn't
interested in supporting terrorism
didn't matter that you know that she
think it's a pro-democracy group
you're with the aclu we know from at
least the 1988 presidential campaign
that that's a liberal organization
did you vote for president obama in
2008. this would be me personally the
aclu is nonpartisan
we have libertarian members as well as
liberal members
and let me see and i hope that you have
some conservative members oh of course
yeah we certainly do but did you vote
for obama in 2008 well i don't think i
should actually be you know
i don't want to be you know because i'm
here in my aclu in author capacity
what i do want to say to you is i think
we have common cause with a lot of
conservatives too
i tell in my book about a lot of places
where the cato institute the rutherford
institute
very much agree with us and are bringing
similar lawsuits and writing similar
concerns
about the big government involved here
right and i think you know no matter
who's running for president you know my
message to the candidates is the same
which is that
you know we're the deciders we're the
governors so i mean there are people
like ron paul and gary johnson running
for the republican nomination or pretty
outspoken on this type of thing but
how do liberals get obama or the obama
administration to take them seriously
because can't
i mean this is part of coalitional
politics can't they just say hey you
know what
uh the obama administration is going to
be you're going to vote for me anyway so
i'm going to
i'm going to run roughshod over this
area of concern
i think what has to happen as you were
saying it's not just obama it's not just
bush it's not just clinton
any foreseeable president will see that
the political winds
favor you're looking tough on terrorism
by keeping feeding us placebos
even if they are placebos so i think it
has to be a broader coalition than only
liberals
glenn greenwald said i think this is
right he said that actually you know
things became harder for the democrats
in congress to
object to all these laws when obama was
taking the same positions as bush
because they were no longer being the
opposition party
so i think what has to happen is all of
our elected representatives
have to hear more from a broad cross
section of liberals libertarians
conservatives
people who just want to say this is too
much big government we want our
government back
historically is there a good example or
a precursor where
uh these kinds of incursions on civil
liberties on very basic civil liberties
were rolled one very good antecedent i
think was the church committee
which after yeah the whole you know
there's people have been talking about
this current movie coming out about j
edgar hoover what's your why should we
worry about the fbi well sometimes you
know the fbi power can be abused
uh j edgar hoover was in fact spying on
martin luther king and various people
the church commission which uh took
place in the 70s and
revealed a huge host of uh civil rights
violations by the national security
administration the cia the fbi
how was that successful though i mean it
revealed a lot of stuff but then here we
are again
well i think there were two ways in
which it had some success
one was they wrote an amazing report
about all the emergency you know
provisions that
we had put into law that somehow they
just get rooted and they stay there even
if they're after the emergency is passed
they also managed in the 70s to come up
with a sort of a compromise solution
which was the foreign intelligence
surveillance act to say let's have one
set of rules for spying on americans
which we want to be a little hard
the government should have to get a
second opinion from a court as opposed
to
if we want to know what the soviet
embassy is up to hey it's the cold war
that should be easy what's happened
after the patriot act is that we've
allowed
the foreign intelligence surveillance
act to be used more and more and more
to spy on americans and it has i mean
the fisa courts have become rubber
stamps haven't they
yeah oh they they approve upward of 99
of the government's applications
so a lot of the amendments that give the
aclu for example is asking about the
patriot act
are really they're they're process
amendments they're nobody is saying
you can never get records what they're
saying is you should have to go to a
court you should have to
show a court that you really have a
reason to get the records and so there's
some check on whether you're being
arbitrary or discriminatory
are you optimistic about the ability to
uh kind of
uh toughen up constitutional protections
of uh
individual citizens yeah i don't think
it's gonna happen in the short run but i
think what has to happen and you this is
where to me
we're back to kind of the framing of the
constitution and what the framers
thought it really depends on us
and i think we kind of got a little off
track in the fall of 2001
and again i think this is a little bit
the war metaphor the idea that we have a
commander-in-chief who's going to decide
everything for us
and that we don't get to make the
decisions and we don't know enough and
we should just trust the government
to decide which of our liberties and
privacy and due process we have to give
up
and i think people have to figure out
that that's not true
and that's only going to happen if
people start asking more questions
instead of just you know i think kind of
putting our heads in the sand and saying
well you know it must be keeping us safe
because you know we haven't had a major
attack well you know
cause and effect i want to thank susan
herman the president of the aclu and the
author of the new book
taking liberties the war on terror and
the erosion of american democracy
for talking with reason tv thank you
thank you
for reason tv i'm nick
you